Oh mg it's G no doubt what does I mean
it's God behind the desk that girl
that's God that blonde ladies god no
it's very very real let me see what
I can do
thank you oh I don't mean to be
disrespectful but I thought they'd be a
little bigger your pup's your sweater
meats pardon me
yep sorry alright disrespect I don't
know what you're talking about
I've only had sex with five girls and
I'm the kind of guy that needs to just
be Slayton babes with my meat sword but
I'm not it's always in the chief and
you're just the woman God to help me
with it okay yeah also why am I not
driven yet I'm a friends are tripping
and I'm not which is bogus God you do
some crazy effed up Chibs sometimes whoa
God has a picture of me so what are you
doing that's my dog Coco help help me I
think this chair is Spanish I don't
speak Spanish I'm not gonna give you
that room number nope that is correct
thank you
you